thank you
the prophet Muhammad
told us whoever builds a mosque for
Allah Allah will build for him a Sim at
the house in Jannah and we know the
great reward that will not only be
gained but rather will fill your grave
after your death
whenever someone prays there whenever
someone gives shahada in the Masjid
whenever someone learns something in the
Masjid yes that will be something that
you'll have on your scale
how are you guys doing I recently came
across a video
of the president of Rwanda responding to
a particular question from a journalist
let's take a look at that and come back
and respond in kind the issue of values
who defines the values
or who doesn't actually
have values
when people talk about value sometimes
it's
is one part of the world
that has assumed their sole
responsibility
and the Monopoly
of defining values
so the rest of us
have no values
we've just
to keep learning from these ones who
Define the values
and and by the way the danger also is
it doesn't matter how we
long we take learning
you will never qualify
you just always be branded
somebody who has no values or who comes
from a place where there are no values
so I want to put this case clear
those from the north who always assume
where BBC comes from
who always think
they are the face of values
the rest have to follow
it's a big mistake it's not true
we have values too we here in Rwanda
in Africa we do no question about it
second
there are some of these problems we have
had in our continent
inner Wonder those from the north who
Define or want to define the values
have been part and parcel of these
problems we have been facing
them have actually been the cause of the
problems we face
I think this was a very good response
not least because the president of
Rwanda was able to trace the Genesis of
ideas if you like back to Western
hegemonic thinking and I particularly
like the second part of what he said
relating to a lot of the problems that
are present not just in sub-Saharan
Africa but across the world
actually have their Inception or the
beginning
from the colonial project which is
obviously delivered by the West itself
and this is very interesting and very
good
I think really and truly when we ask
when we speak about morality and we saw
this with Qatar hosting the World Cup
and it's all about human rights as if
it's some kind of a universal concept
one has to really remember that it's not
really a universal concept their
understanding of human rights has a
beginning
there are 30 articles in the United
Nations Charter
of Human Rights was not designed by a
conglomerate of individuals from all
parts of the world
who all agreed with different
ideological standpoints that these are
Universal human rights
some things have been omitted some
things have been added which the rest of
the world simply doesn't agree with
and as to the point
with the economic problems that much of
sub-Saharan Africa continues to struggle
from because of the western world
because of American particular for
example
with these major IMF loans that have
been issued to many of these countries
then that's another reason why we
shouldn't be listening to you if you
want to put it candidly but I like the
fact that this president was able to
identify these points I think he done a
good job
and I think more of us need to be
clever enough in being able to
unpack these kinds of assumptions
especially when people from let's say a
liberal standpoint with a small L come
to us with these kinds of questions why
is it that your religion why is it that
your people why is it like your country
doesn't uphold a vision of human rights
commensurate with the Western World View
the reason is because we simply have a
different Paradigm now the fight is or
the intellectual debate should be
which one is right
hey you are you wasting your time on
social media again your brothers
and sislam net from
nourishing a message
establishing a Masjid to convey The
Message of Islam is one of the best
Deeds a Muslim can do there's a huge
need for it in Norway you know this and
I know this so that makes the world even
greater so give generously and Allah
azzawajal give you even